Israel looks set to take on travel
accommodation giant air B&B after the
company removed home listings located in
the Israeli occupied West Bank from its
website a B&B says the move was done to
political reasons in the disputed
territory we concluded that we should
remove listings in Israeli settlements
in the occupied West Bank that are at
the core of the dispute between Israelis
and Palestinians around 200 listings
will be affected with the decision set
to take effect in the coming days the
company says it decided to remove the
listings after determining they were in
Israeli settlements which are disputed
with Palestinians the move was welcomed
by the Palestinian administration which
had previously asked the company to end
its relationship with Israeli
settlements Israel is condemning the
decision calling it discriminatory this
decision is something completely
unacceptable this is pure discrimination
something that is taken only against
Jews that are living in Judea and
Samaria this is actually a racist
decision and more than that I do believe
that is a double standard that is only
taken against Israel against Jews that
are living here in Israel we heard from
the general secretary of the Palestinian
national initiative and a former colonel
in the Israel army for their views on
air BnB s decision the international law
the United Nations resolutions say that
settlements are illegal and they are
themselves discriminatory because they
are built on stolen land from
Palestinians and that any relationship
with these illegal settlements is a
violation of international law our B&B
just taken has just taken the right
decision because they also realized that
they will lose a lot because of the
boycott campaign against them due to
their violation of international law
what is really racist and discriminatory
is the system of apartheid that Israel
has created in the occupied Palestinian
territories which is favoring Israel is
to Palestinians this should be a
commercial company a commercial trading
between our apartment's etc so that
tend to be as a result of being cowards
or pressure being made by Islamic
terrorists I don't know what but if you
look for a backward to the history of
anti-semitism or the history of ignoring
the right of the Jews to their homeland
the biblical homeland of Judea and
Samaria know how many Christians are now
angry about this this this step this is
an awful step being made against history
against faith
you